[Musique]
on vient d'entendre près de 250
collaborateurs travaillent ici sur le
site de merck à guyancourt un centre de
recherches et de développements
marketing pour concevoir des systèmes de
purification d'eau a une activité un
présentes sur le territoire depuis plus
de 30 ans d'abord millipore puis merck
depuis 2010 et pour en parler nous
sommes avec renault bars dont le
dirigeant de ce site bonjour bonjour
[Musique]
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
quel métier on retrouve ici on retrouve
beaucoup de types de métiers
principalement de niveau bac +5 et
doctorants et en général on a des bien
sûr des scientifiques mais pour tout ce
qui est purification de l'eau des
chimistes des biochimistes mais aussi
nous avons et ça c'est un petit peu
moins connu beaucoup avec la
transformation digitale de besoin en
électronicien informaticien et bien sûr
comme c'est un centre marketing de
fonctions marketing donc toutes ces
activités sont dédiés à la purification
de l'eau des systèmes qui permettent de
purifier l'eau c'est ça oui en fait on
est très fiers d'être les leaders du
marché au niveau mondial et toute la
recherche et développement et le
marketing sont faits à partir du site de
guyancourt
alors quelle est la stratégie autour de
cette innovation la stratégie allez
allez multiples la première c'est de
garder ce leadership bien sûr et tout ça
en misant sur l'innovation l'innovation
mais aussi la qualité et comme je vous
le disais cette transformation digitale
dont beaucoup parlent et qui est une
réelle réalité pour nous puisque nous
avons par exemple la possibilité de
consulter les données de nos systèmes à
distance ce qui pendant le coc vide a
été critique pour de nombreux hôpitaux
de pouvoir compter sur leurs systèmes de
purification d'eau et de savoir qu'on
n'avait pas besoin de venir sur site
pour consulter leurs performances
comment vous l'expliquez ce leadership
on a une très très bonne recherche et
développement avec des gens très
compétents
nous faisons partie du plateau pas loin
de saclay avec beaucoup de très bonnes
écoles
pareil pour le marketing ne rejouer en
josas on à hec qui est pas loin et c'est
donc une qualité de la ressource qui est
très très bonne autour de lui en cours
vous le dit hein un leadership une
qualité autour des compétences et donc
une activité croissante
c'est pour cela que vous recherchez de
nouveaux collaborateurs bien sûr on
recherche des collaborateurs des
collaborateurs au top niveau
on a aussi eu on est aussi engagé dans
le développement durable
donc tout ce qui nous apporte un
avantage en termes de techniques de
purification d'eau mais aussi de
l'empreinte carbone autour de nos
systèmes nous donne cet avantage
compétitif
cette innovation qui permet de rester en
avance par rapport à tout ce qui les
compétitions un dernier mot au bar dont
quel type de profil vous recherchez du
coup actuellement
donc on recherche alors bien sûr au
niveau de la société merck
on est très connu pour tout ce qui est
chimie biochimie donc donc là dessus on
n'a pas de gros problèmes de recrutement
en revanche pour tout ce qui est
marketing et pour tout ce qui est
informatique et électronique
là en revanche on est un petit peu moins
connus et les gens même si on a de très
bonnes écoles dans le coin ne pense pas
à nous
et c'est plus difficile pour nous de
recruter dans ces domaines là merci
renaud bardon merci beaucoup à vous je
rappelle que vous êtes le dirigeant du
site de merck à guyancourt et on va tout
de suite rejoindre perrine projet votre
directrice marketing pour voir comment
fonctionnent ces systèmes de
purification d'eau
[Musique]
nous avons rejoint intérim projet la
directrice marketing du groupe merck sur
le site de guyancourt bonjour bonjour et
bienvenu merci nous accueillir dans un
laboratoire où on voit différents
systèmes de purification d'eau alors
est-ce que vous pouvez nous à nous
expliquer à quoi servent ces systèmes
tout à fait alors ce qu'il faut savoir
déjà c'est que l'eau de ville bien
qu'elle soit propre à notre consommation
contient beaucoup de composer ionique ou
organiques qui ne sont pas compatibles
avec les expérimentations scientifiques
notre rôle c'est de concevoir des
systèmes qui vont purifier cet autre
ville pour la rendre propre à
l'utilisation par les scientifiques
que ce soit dans la recherche contre la
cancérologie par exemple en cancérologie
ou pour ce soit des analyses chimiques
dans l'environnement l'alimentaire en
fait ces systèmes servent à la recherche
scientifique
c'est l'eau utilisée dans les recherches
scientifiques ans et ça c'est un composé
indispensable un réactif indispensable
pour la recherche scientifique
c'est également absolument essentiel
pour les laboratoires de biologie
clinique qui ont été au coeur de la
lutte contre le coc vide nos systèmes
permettent le bon fonctionnement de ces
laboratoires et donc nous avons nous
avons été très impliquée dans la
continuité du service et le support à
ces laboratoires dans les derniers mois
c'est le système qui sont utilisés dans
la production de vaccins par exemple
dans la recherche dans le cadre de
production de vaccins ils sont tout à
fait utiliser dans le cadre de la
recherche de production de vaccins dans
le cadre des contrôles qualité à des
vaccins donc là dans le cadre de la
crise
votre activité marketing a été
essentielle jusqu'en notre activité non
seulement marketing mais aussi
innovation support à nos clients dans
des conditions d'acompte connaît
donc oui nous avons été très présent et
très sollicité alors concrètement
comment ça fonctionne en fait ce système
alors c'est sont des systèmes qui
embarque différentes technologies de
purification donc de la filtration de
l'osmose inverse de la photo oxydation
uv mais aussi beaucoup de technologie de
contrôle pour vraiment être capable de
mesurer le degré purification et de
restituer aux clients toutes les
informations dont il a besoin au moment
où il va l'utiliser
alors vous allez utiliser plusieurs
termes techniques concrètement comment
on purifient l'eau en fait qu'est-ce qui
agit au niveau microscopique finalement
alors l'ol va passer dans des colonnes
de charbon actif par exemple qui vont
capter les contaminants elle va être
soumis donc à la photo oxydation iv qui
va tuer les bactéries donc en fait
chaque étape de purification va
permettre d'atteindre un degré
purification a plus élevée de l'eau pour
au final ne garder que l'eau ultra purs
qui va permettre la conduite des
expérimentations renault bardon nous
disait tout à l'heure que finalement
vous utilisez beaucoup liothier
aujourd'hui s'est connecté en fait ce
sont des appareils connectés
et puis on peut les piloter à distance
en fait exactement donc ce sont des
encore une fois la purification est très
importante mais là tout le contrôle de
cette purification la mesure permanente
des paramètres de qualité de l'eau est
essentielle et aujourd'hui nos
technologies permettent de donner ces
paramètres à nos clients bien qu'il ne
soit pas devant leur système dont qui
peuvent consulter la performance de
leurs systèmes à 10 ans
nous sommes aussi en mesure de réparer
leur système à distance c'est à dire que
vous êtes au début de la filière jusqu'à
la fin de la filière de la purification
de l'eau sur dans le cadre de la santé
tout à fait dans le cadre des sciences
de la vie avec des applications en santé
notamment
merci père une projets pour ces détails
avec grand plaisir l'éventuelle que vous
êtes la directrice marketing du groupe
merck sur le site de guyancourt